I hated that job and I clung to that job
10 years in a place without heat,
six years at a job.
I felt stuck in.
Maybe I was afraid of change.
Are you?
When I was 29,
I told myself the next acting job I get,
no matter what it pays,
I will from now on,
for better or worse be a working actor
now.
I didn't have either the internet or a
cellphone or a job,
but something good happened.
I got a loping theater job in a play
called imperfect love,
which led to a film called 13 moons with
the same writer which led to other roles
which led to other roles and I've worked
as an actor ever since.
I didn't know that would happen at 29,
walking away from data processing.
I was terrified,
but this made me very hungry.
Literally
I couldn't be lazy.
Now I tell this story because the world
might say,
you are not allowed to yet.
Please don't even bother asking.
Don't bother telling the world you
already show it.
Do it.
Trust me.
Rhythm sets in.
Just try not to wait until like me,
your 29 before you find it,
and if you are,
that's fine too.
Some of us never find it,
but you will.
I promise you,
raise the rest of your life to meet you.
Don't search for defining moments
because they will never come.
The moments that define you have already
happened and they will already happen
again.
Don't wait until they tell you you are
ready.
Get in there.
I waited a long time out in the world
before I gave myself permission to fail.
What did becky say?
Ever tried,
ever failed.
No matter.
Try again.
Fail again.
Fail better.
The world is yours.
Treat everyone kindly and light up the
night.
Thank you so much for having me here.